the PS5 has been out for less than three
years but a higher spec version may
already be in development just keep in
mind this has not been confirmed by Sony
and you should be taking this report
with a grain of salt Insider gaming
claims that a hypothetical PlayStation 5
is already in the works and that Sony is
reportedly targeting a late 2024 release
window like the PS4 Pro this PS5 Pro
would have better specs than the base
console allowing for better visuals and
performance the report goes on to cite a
recent Patent filed by PlayStation
console architect Mark Cerny that looks
to boost the performance of Ray tracing
Tech as a possible reason for the
PlayStation 5 Pro as for whether or not
this move to a PS5 Pro makes sense is
very much Up For Debate we've just
started to see ps5s on store shelves
more often following the chip shortages
that limited the supply I also can't
help but feel like we've yet to see the
limits of the standard PlayStation 5
push yet as most of its games have also
been released on the PlayStation 4.
maybe naughty dog's next game will be
the one to push the PlayStation 5. and
even though we don't know what that game
is yet The Last of Us co-creator Neil
druckman does in an interview with kind
of funny druckman acknowledges the hype
of a potential Last of Us Part three but
stops short of confirming if that will
indeed be the team's next project Neil
said quote I know the fans really want
The Last of Us Part three I hear it all
the time all I can say is that we're
already into our next project the
decision has already been made I can't
say what it is but that is the process
we went through druckman goes on to
clarify that the unnamed Last of Us
multiplayer game is the Studio's next
big title so presumably the project he
couldn't describe is the major title
that will come after this release
another PlayStation news we already know
one of PlayStation Plus's free games for
April 2023 Behavior interactive's brand
new game meet your maker will be
available on the service starting April
4th the same day the game launched
watches meteor maker is referred to as a
building and raiding game it takes place
in a post-apocalyptic world where Earth
is on the brink of total Annihilation
both the building and raiding portions
of meet your maker are played from a
first person perspective when you're
rating you'll get to pick between three
unique loadouts ranged melee and
defensive there's an arsenal of guns and
close range weapons such as swords at
your disposal all tiers of PlayStation
Plus will be able to claim meet your
maker throughout April and assuming that
PlayStation doesn't view meet your maker
as one of the rare bonus freebies it'll
take up one of the three slots in
April's PlayStation Plus lineup in the
meantime don't forget to claim March's
PlayStation Plus lineup which includes
Battlefield 2042 Minecraft dungeons and
code vein thanks for watching we'll see
you tomorrow
foreign